Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I’m
going to explain a Horror Sci Fi film
called “As The Gods Will,” Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
At the beginning of the movie, 3 students;
Shun, Amaya and Ichika are shown as a voice
in the background complains to god
about his dull and boring life.
In the next scene, we see Shun along with his
friends in the college classroom where a doll
named Daruma doll has forced the students to
play a game. The game is Daruma-san ga Koronda,
where an ugly-looking Daruma doll with only a
head is seen on the desk in front of the students.
The doll turns around after he sings,
and if he finds someone moving,
he kills them and turns them into red marbles.
The remaining students start worrying as they are
unaware of the game rules and might
end up joining their dead friends.
One by one their number starts decreasing. Two
of the boys try to open the door to escape but
find it locked. They are caught moving
by the doll and are killed immediately.
Suddenly, a gamer boy approaches everyone
to read the message at the back of the doll.
The message says that the game will be over if
they press the button. A guy quickly runs to
press the button but the doll turns around and
kills him. Suddenly, Shun notices that there’s a
timer on the back of the doll and realizes that
they don't have much time left. Hearing this,
several other students run to switch it
off but every single one of them fails.
At last, only Shun and the gamer boy remain as
all other students are turned into red marbles,
making it impossible for them to reach the
doll without slipping. With time running out,
the gamer comes up with an idea and tells Shun
to use his back to jump over the dead bodies
to press the button easily. Shun finally presses
the button, thus ending the game. As the survivors
are celebrating, the doll declares Shun
the only winner and kills the gamer.
The movie then cuts to the past when
life was boring and normal for Shun.
He is sitting on a couch, playing video games and
changing channels after the game ends. At school,
he is walking with his gamer friend, who
suggests he ask Ichika out as she passes a
smile to him. Ichika is another student in the
school who also loves to play video games. Shun
answers that he does not have any feelings for
her and sees her only as a friend. Both of them
head towards the classroom when they meet a boy
being beaten up by Amaya; the school bully.
Inside the classroom, Shun gets asleep and a loud
sound wakes him up. Just then, his teacher’s head
explodes and the Daruma doll appears. The events
at the start of the movie continue from here.
At present, Shun starts praying to God to
return him to his boring life. The Daruma
doll mentions Shun as a mouse and tells him that
a cat is coming for him very soon. Meanwhile,
Ichika Akimoto approaches Shun’s classroom and
is horrified after seeing it's condition.
Shun asks her if she knows what's happening
but she says that she's as confused as he is.
They try to call the police but find no signal.
They then try to flee the school but all the
exits and doors are locked. The duo then run
from the scene towards the basketball court
where they are surprised to see some students in
mice costumes, who survived the daruma doll.
They look at the floor and find
the words ‘ “fit the cat’s bell
for it to end”. The school president then
orders them to wear the mice costumes.
Just then, the floor of the court opens up and
a gigantic plastic cat appears from beneath.
The big cat starts gobbling the students one by
one,which sends everyone into a state of panic.
Shun notices the ball-like bell with
a timer on it. He quickly informs
everyone that in order to end the game,
the bell must be passed through the basket
placed on the cat’s neck. One of the students,
who is a good basketball player, shoots the bell,
but the cat manages to catch it, and throws it
back at the student, killing him instantly.
Shun seems to be a genius and quickly notices that
the cat is killing only those who are wearing the
mice costume. He then suggests everyone remove the
costume to which everyone complies. For a while,
the cat remains idle but as the students start
celebrating, the cat devours another one.
The students start screaming and running again
and Ichika falls on the floor amidst the chaos.
Shun immediately gets into the mouse costume and
starts to distract the cat. He realizes that by
wearing the costume, one can hear the voice of
the cat. All this time, the poor cat was just
requesting them to scratch its back so that it
could sleep quietly. Shun quickly gets on its back
and starts scratching it. He then tells the others
to join him and the cat finally falls asleep.
Now that the cat is asleep, Shun grabs the
bell and proceeds to throw it over the hoop.
The other students however, stop him as they
think that the only one who scores the bell
will be the winner. Ultimately, they
all start quarreling with each other.
As they are fighting, the cat wakes up
and starts attacking the students again.
Shun comes up with a plan once again. He
takes Ichika inside and conceals the bell
in a regular basketball to deceive the cat. As
they throw the ball and are ready to celebrate,
the bell bounces on the ring but suddenly,
Amaya arrives in the nick of time and heroically
scores the shot, thus ending the game.
The cat then declares that only Shun, Ichika,
and Amaya can live. Shun asks about the fate of
the losers but before he gets an answer, Amaya
kills the remaining students. Amaya then says that
only the strongest will survive, which is God's
will. Amaya approaches Shun and tells him that
both of them are alike as they have what it takes
to survive. Ichika on the other hand disagrees and
mentions Shun being kinder, stronger, and smarter
than Amaya. On hearing this Amaya is infuriated
and tries to attack her but the cat sprays a gas
from its mouth and knocks them all out.
In the next scene, a news channel is seen
reporting about the incidents happening around the
schools as a terrorist attack. Another news report
shows large cubes hovering above the cities and
mentions the defense and the police departments
are yet to find any entrance into the cube despite
various attempts. The media also reveals that the
survivors of the incident are God’s children as
they are able to survive such a tough situation.
Some media and interviewers along with
the professor from a university are seen
mentioning the incident as the alien invasion of
human existence. Next, we see a homeless person
repairing a damaged radio just by touching it.
Later, Shun wakes up in one of the cubes. Among
the other survivors he finds Takumi, his childhood
friend along with a shy and timid girl Tiara and
an arrogant but intelligent student Taoka. Shun
is disappointed in finding himself playing the
death game again. He tries to escape but finds
all the doors locked. Taoka then informs him that
the only way to escape the room is by winning it.
He also brags that his intelligence will lead him
to victory. Through a screen, they are informed
that they have to find the keys to escape.
Just then, 4 wooden dolls enter the room. They
introduce themselves and the rules of the game.
They say that each of the participants will be
blindfolded and the dolls will circle them singing
songs. When the song stops, the participant
will have to guess which of the four floating
Kokeshi wooden dolls is behind them within 10
seconds. Failing to guess correctly would result
in their death. However, if the Kokeshi dolls
lose, one of them will explode, releasing an
answer key that will open the doors and allow the
survivors to go to the next level. The confident
Taoka goes first and Tiara second. But both of
them fail to answer and are ultimately killed.
The dolls then approach Takumi next but Shun
insists on going first. With the help of his
intelligence, he wins the game as he was able
to note the difference in their voices with the
help of his phone. He then reveals that he had
recorded their voices when Tiara was playing.
After the game ends, the dolls explode leaving
behind a key which Shun grabs. He then leaves
the room along with Takumi. Outside, they see a
guy being chased by an ugly-looking doll. The guy
approaches them and requests them to hold his hand
to save his life. He mentions that the dolls can't
hurt those holding hands. They decide to help
him out and the doll leaves saying that he is
jealous of those whose friendship is strong.
Shun looks at the pendant Takumi is wearing
and goes into a flashback. There, Takumi
is ready to commit suicide from a rooftop
when she notices Shun smashing cups and glasses
onto a wall to release his anger. Shun then offers
Takumi to do the same and she starts breaking
the crockery, which makes her feel better.
At present, she is wearing the same
cup handle that Shun had offered her.
Suddenly, they hear a girl’s voice
screaming from the other side.
They run towards the scream and find Ichika
running away from the same dreadful doll. Shun
jumps to hold her hand immediately and saves her.
Soon after, a wall erodes and reveals a doll’s
face with 7 of the key entries. Shun and his
group reach the place where 2 contestants
are already waiting. They count their keys
but find that 3 of them are still missing.
Suddenly, Amaya appears at the scene with the
remaining keys and kills his companion as only
seven of them are able to qualify for the next
round. When all of the 7 locks are unlocked,
the doll face announces them as the winners
and it erodes backward into the wall,
making a passage-like structure. Then, a voice
directs them to follow the passage by wearing the
costumes provided. Here, it is revealed that all
the games are telecasted all over the country.
Next, the group finds themselves inside a frozen
room. A large polar bear enters and introduces
himself. He mentions that he hates liars and
black hearted people. In the game, the contestants
just have to do one thing: speak the truth.
Failing to do so will result in their death.
The game begins when he asks everyone about
their favorite food. After they reply,
the bear suspects someone of lying. The bear gives
the participants 2 minutes to present the liar.
At first they defend their answers but later
all point towards the guy who answered Parsley.
The bear then instantly stomps him to death.
For the second question, the bear asks if they
like Shun. All of them who know Shun including
Takumi answer Yes and the others who don't know
him answer No. The bear still believes that one
of them is lying to him and again suggests the
remaining participants to name the liar. All
of the participants answer Takumi as the liar
as Shun and Takumi were out of contact for a long
time. Despite Shun’s best attempts to save Takumi,
she gets killed. Devastated by the loss of
his friend, Shun screams that the liar and
traitor among them is none other than the
white bear himself. It turns out to be true
and the bear sheds his white color and reveals
his original color to be black. As all the lies
are caught, the game officially ends, and the
survivors are taken to the last game.
The remaining five participants are taken to
a temple. After the door opens, three wooden
dolls welcome them and also congratulate them
for making it this far. The three of the dolls
introduce themselves as fitness, intelligence,
and imagination. They reveal the last game name
as “Kick the can for it to end”. One of the
participants will be the Demon and the rest
will be the Victims. Until the demon places the
can to the designated place, the victims will get
their time to hide. The demon will then have to
find all the victims. He will have to name them
after seeing their faces, after which he can
imprison them inside the cells. In this way, if he
imprisons them all, and kicks the can, he will be
the winner. However, if a victim manages to kick
the can, the other victims will be considered the
winners and the demon will lose. But, the victim
who kicks the can, will die as the can explodes.
Then, the five take turns picking a stick,
with the red stick going to the Demon. Amaya
obtains the red stick. He quickly places the can
on the ground and starts searching for the others.
Two of the students are quickly captured. Ichika
then sacrifices herself in order to distract Amaya
while Shun escapes. After imprisoning Ichika,
Amaya screams that he doesn't need to find Shun to
win the game. And despite Ichika’s advice to hide,
Shun comes out wearing an armored suit,
with which he is hiding his face.
Shun then tells Amaya that it is impossible for
him to get caught as his face is covered up. Amaya
finds this ridiculous and he quickly takes off
Shun’s helmet. As Amaya proceeds to kick the can
and end the game, he realizes that Shun has
attached an iron chain to him. Shun then jumps
into the water and starts dragging Amaya with him.
As Amaya struggles to pull Shun out of the water,
he sees that Shun has removed the armor
and is slowly proceeding towards the can.
Suddenly, Amaya manages to break free
and runs towards the can but Shun kicks
it first before him. They prepare for
the explosion but nothing happens.
The game is finally over and the dolls declare
everyone winners except Amaya. They also reveal
that the explosion was just a lie to make the game
even more interesting. An enraged Amaya then grabs
one of the dolls and says that he isn't supposed
to die as he was chosen by God. The dolls start
laughing and reveal that no one was supposed
to die. The winners are then congratulated with
fireworks in the sky. The dolls also provide
some ice creams to celebrate their success.
While eating the ice cream, Shun finally asks
Ichika for a movie date and also expresses
his feelings for her. Ichika happily
agrees but when their ice creams melt,
they see something written on the sticks. The
dolls then reveal that despite making it this far,
they need luck to live.
Amaya and Shun notice the words
‘you live’ on their sticks while the other
3 including Ichika find the words ‘you die’.
A doll then kills the losers as Shun watches in
horror while Ichika disappears into thin air.
Shun and Amaya finally emerge from the cube,
where they are cheered by a large crowd.
They are calling them God's children.
Amaya rejoices, but Shun bends down in despair,
declaring "there is no God" after all of his
losses. One of the dolls corrects him, saying
that God does exist. The movie ends as the same
homeless man from before is revealed to be God.
Subscribe for more videos like
this, turn on notifications,
and leave a like to help the channel out.
Thank you for watching.